the development of technology like
electric vehicles
or green hydrogen for that matter for
heavy transport
is vital for maintaining the health of
our world
for future generations something i'm
only
too aware of today having recently
become a grandfather for the fifth time
prince charles is delighted to have a
new grandchild
on tuesday the 72 year old royal
attended his first public event since
the news that his son
prince harry and daughter-in-law meghan
markle had welcomed their second child
a daughter named lillabet diana visiting
the bmw
mini factory in oxford england the
prince of wales spoke about the newborn
baby girl publicly
for the very first time the development
of technology like electric vehicles or
green hydrogen for that matter for heavy
transport
is vital for maintaining the health of
our world
for future generations something i'm
only
too aware of today having recently
become a grandfather for the fifth time
and such happy news really does remind
well of the necessity of continued
innovation
in this area especially around
sustainable battery technology
in view of the legacy we bequeath to our
grandchildren
shortly after the baby's arrival on june
4th
charles and his wife camilla the duchess
of cornwall
tweeted their excitement writing quote
congratulations to harry megan
and archie on the arrival of baby
lillabet diana
wishing them all well at this special
time i think there is a desire on both
parts to move on
from this family risk despite the kind
words etie has learned that the
relationship between charles and his
youngest son
is still strained following harry and
megan's decision to step down as senior
members of the royal family in january
2020
and their march 2021 tell-all interview
with oprah winfrey where they accused an
unnamed member of the royal family of
expressing concern about the potential
color of their son archie's skin
before he was born everyone's hope is
that this
little baby is going to be a rift healer
um because
this family division has really gone on
for
a very long time now it's well over a
year it's been
many many months since charles the queen
indeed the cambridges have seen
archie in the flesh and we know that
there have been
some really quite deep problems between
harry and william
difficulties between harry and his
father and i think it's everyone's hope
that this little baby will will be a
peace offering
in many ways and that she will help to
bring this divided family
back together a source recently told et
that the royal family made a coordinated
public effort to congratulate and offer
harry and megan well wishes on social
media
after the birth of baby lily but the
source adds that there are still
quote lingering feelings of
disappointment and anger
after the couple's claims in their
explosive oprah interview
the couple have named their daughter
lily bert
diana mountbatten windsor which is
quite a royal name of course megan and
harry's daughter's name
sweetly honors two incredibly special
women queen elizabeth ii
and the late princess diana in a
statement the couple explained that
lillabet is harry's grandmother's family
nickname
and diana was chosen to honor harry's
late mother
i've long heard that if prince harry
ever had a little girl
he was always going to honor his
mother's name and give her diana as one
of her names but i think the greatest
surprise has been lily bert which
actually many people don't even know
is an affectionate nickname that was
given to the queen when she was little
she couldn't pronounce elizabeth it came
out lily bet when she was just two
and it was such a cute and lovely name
it's stuck
you